(police sirens screech outside)
(truck horn honks)
- [Interviewer] Alright, El.
- Hello.
- [Interviewer] El, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Well, I'm originally from Burbank.
I grew up in orange County.
I lived down South for a little bit
and then traveled back to California.
- [Interviewer] Can you
tell me about your family?
You had, both your parents?
- No, my mother is deceased
and my dad is in Texas.
- [Interviewer] Did your mom raise you?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you?
- I'm 19.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- I'm pretty quiet.
I tend to stay, I try to stay to myself.
I do enjoy new things.
I can be kind of eccentric sometimes.
- [Interviewer] But your
childhood wasn't traumatic,
no abuse, nothing like that?
- I mean, when I was younger,
my mom's, my mom's brother,
I was molested when I
was, when I was nine.
I left my mom's home when I was 16.
Thank you.
- [Interviewer] That went on for how long?
- About, up until I left, actually.
- [Interviewer] Oh. Really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Did you
finished high school?
- Yes. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You started working
as a prostitute at what age?
- I started working as a
prostitute when I was 16,
when I left my mom's house.
I mean, I had to figure out
how I was gonna get basic necessities
and I still wanted to make sure
I finished school at least.
So I was staying with a friend
until her parents found out
that I was like there, like found some
of my clothes and whatnot.
So I had to leave from there.
- [Interviewer] And
you're working with a pimp
or on your own?
- I have a pimp.
It's made thing a bit, in some
ways, a lot more difficult,
in other ways, it's I guess
helpful, one could say.
- [Interviewer] What, in
what ways is it helpful?
- Well, I've been robbed before.
I've been raped on the track before.
I've sat in jail so-
- [Interviewer] So the
pimp comes and helps you
when those things happen?
- Well, yeah. Yeah.
When, when I went to jail, he bail me out
so I wasn't in there that long.
- [Interviewer] What's the
downside of having a pimp?
- When you, when you don't
bring in what's expected of you.
- [Interviewer] What happens?
- I've had multiple black eyes.
I've, my jaw has been broken.
A bloody nose, broke a rib.
For me, the alternative of
being beat up and robbed-
- [Interviewer] Because you're renegade?
- Right. It's not...
- [Interviewer] You're damned if you do
and you're damned if you don't.
- Basically.
- [Interviewer] And if
you wanted to get out,
is that even an option?
- I would like to say it's an option.
- [Interviewer] It should be an option.
- I can't say I necessarily feel
like it's an option right now.
So, I guess my honest
answer would probably be no.
- [Interviewer] Thank
you for being honest.
You're one of the few.
(sighs)
So, what is your, how
much do you have to make
before you can show up?
- I have to make six.
- [Interviewer] 600?
- Yeah.
And it doesn't even matter
what the weather's like
and whether...
(sighs)
- [Interviewer] Do you, do
you feel like you were tricked
into that relationship?
Like he seduced you as a boyfriend
and then turned into something different?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Just psych. Big dramatic change
that I didn't even see
coming in the least bit.
- [Interviewer] What
emotions does this lifestyle
bring up in you?
Anxiety, depression, anger?
- All the above and just
anguish and loneliness.
It's just an endless
cycle of pain, just...
- [Interviewer] Are drugs
a part of your life?
- They were, yeah.
I'm glad to say I don't partake anymore
but at one point, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And tell me
about the men who pick you up.
Do you respect and like them, or?
- Well, for the most part, men
typically see just an object
so I tend to just blank
it all out so to speak.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
The drugs help with that.
- Yeah.
Then you have those like selective few
who are genuine and respectful.
But those are far and few.
- [Interviewer] You work the
street, you work Figueroa?
- Yeah.
I've work Figueroa, I've worked Western,
I've worked in El Monte,
I've worked in Vegas, along the strip.
- [Interviewer] Are you saving money?
- Hm?
- I try to
'till someone finds it and...
- [Interviewer] But you're,
you're giving all your money
each night to your pimp?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So that makes it difficult
for you to-
- Try and save things, yeah.
- [Interviewer] I would think that's hard.
- I try and like hide some things
so I can like put into like a
small piggy bank or something
and someone ends up
finding it or something
and right back to square one.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think most people
don't understand about what you do?
- A lot of people don't understand that,
like, although there
are so-called services
to help, help you manage everyday life,
those services don't actually do much.
They do the bare minimum.
And even when you try and
stay on a straight path,
there's always something or someone
that's gonna try and deter you
and to make you feel like their options
of what you should be
doing are a lot better
than what you're currently doing.
And at the moment it'll
sound, It'll sound pretty,
pretty appetizing until, until it isn't.
- [Interviewer] What do you mean?
- Like,
at first, when we were dating,
he never put his hands on me.
And then it was like
presented to me in a sense of,
this will be helping both of us.
And then after I agreed,
then I found out about other,
other women that I knew nothing about
and then it's just been
an endless stream of just,
(sighs)
just an endless stream of lies, like-
- [Interviewer] And the
deception gets worse and worse
as it goes on?
- So much worse.
And it's like, this person is
telling you that they love you
and they care about you, but...
And in some ways, they show
you that they do, but then...
(sighs)
It makes it really difficult
to believe anything anyone says.
- [Interviewer] I think you're very young.
Do you see that maybe this,
what you're doing for money
is changing the way you view men?
Because you're probably
interacting with a group of men
that are not the most
stand-up guys in the world.
- That's a way to put it.
Yeah. I guess I've kind
of been jaded in a way.
- [Interviewer] That's what I mean.
Yeah, you'll end up having
a very negative view
of men and relationships
after doing this for a while.
- Yeah. And my, my
problems that I encountered
during my upbringing
weren't so pro-male either.
- [Interviewer] Right. Yeah, those are,
those are the beginning of your problems.
- So,
yeah, my outlook on men
is not the most positive
to say the least.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
As someone who's just heard
a lot of these stories
from girls like yourself,
what strikes me is that
it seems like everyone
that you're interacting with,
all the other girls on the street,
the pimps, the tricks, even
the cops I think are probably-
- Wanting something.
- [Interviewer] Everybody's,
everybody wants something.
Everybody's up to no good.
Everybody's deceitful.
Everybody's kind of out for
their own self-interest.
And it's just a hard
environment to go out there
and work really hard and
risk your life every night.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That
would really get to me.
- It's difficult.
But I mean, I look around
at the alternatives
and my optimism is non-existent basically.
- [Interviewer] Well, what
do you think would help you?
Think big.
- My own home that,
that I wouldn't have to like worry about
if my stuff is going to come up missing
or if I don't make this
certain amount of money
then I'm not gonna be let in
'cause I have my own set of house keys.
- [Interviewer] Right.
Do you secretly hope for someone,
like one of your customers
to save you and take you away from this?
- Sometimes.
And then I think about what
that person would then expect.
- [Interviewer] The
strings would be attached.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] The expectations. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It seems
like even the people
who say they have no expectations
end up having expectations.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I mean that, I know that's
a part of human nature,
we expect something from, from everyone,
but I mean, you'd be
surprised how many people
are so deceptive (laughs)
and its unnecessary.
- [Interviewer] Did you have
dreams of doing something
with your life when you were younger?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're still young but,
what did you dream about?
- I wanted to be a pediatric surgeon.
- [Interviewer] You know,
you can still do that.
You were a good student?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
You seem very intelligent.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think you're addicted
to this lifestyle or do
you feel more trapped?
- I feel more trapped than anything else?
It's like everywhere I turn.
- [Interviewer] So if you
working Figueroa Street,
you're probably working in the sixties.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And of the
girls that work the sixties,
they're pretty much all with pimps?
- To my knowledge, yeah.
I mean, it's possible that they're not
but I try not to interact too much.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Because sometimes he
rides around and like,
he'll get, like, he'll get really mad.
- [Interviewer] At what?
- Like if you see me talking to other,
other women out there that
are working and I don't know,
it's like he assumes that
I'm plotting something or,
he's really paranoid.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned?
You've only been doing this a couple years
but what have you learned?
- I've learned that,
everyone's word isn't bond.
Everyone is not gonna
say what they truly mean
or how they truly feel,
what they're truly thinking.
It's up to me to have
to try and decipher it
and figure it out 'cause
listening to people,
I could end up in so many
more horrible situations.
Thinking that just because
they're female like me, so,
why would they wanna cause me harm
if I've never done anything to them?
(sighs)
Well,
yeah, that has to be the
one thing I've learned,
not to trust the words of others.
Only words I can trust are my own.
- [Interviewer] Well El,
thank you so much for talking
with me,
and being honest. (laughs)
That's rare. I appreciate it.
And I wish you the best of luck
with whatever you want to do.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.